what's up what's up world check up fit
world wish world malcolm williams
rugged mc bassist for nomadic massive
international hip-hop band from montreal
[Music]
nomadic message started out as a
collective but morphed into a live
hip-hop
band the group started officially in
2004
in montreal
[Music]
i came here as a refugee when i was a
teenager
one of the underlying themes is the
topic of identity as immigrants since we
express ourselves in different languages
then the listener will then identify
themselves with that little piece of
nomadic
how many languages are in songs in our
band
uh i'd say at least five no i think
you're wrong more french
spanish arabic
so a lot of times if one of us gets the
inspiration and starts a course in
english then one of the emcees might
really feel his story or his piece in
french and some of us just express
ourselves better in our native tongues
that combination could not have come
together anywhere else the way it has
come in montreal
[Music]
montreal is a microcosm of the world you
see different ethnic backgrounds and
cultural groups
people coming up to us and say wow this
was my favorite show because i just i
just felt so positive and included
[Music]
this experience of understanding
multiple languages in one song is very
montreal
[Music]
you